I feel like what they need to do is have
a big shaker - peach holders need to
exit this week it's been about two
months since we last checked in on you
how is quarantine now eight weeks later
actually we're doing very good trying to
keep my mind off of a craziness as much
as possible by indulging in the
craziness that is your show yes your
first virtual reunion did you what was
your feeling about the virtual reunion
did you like it more than a regular one
virtual actually the virtual probably
was better because there were people who
normally wouldn't begin our was it kind
of like the keyboard warriors came to
life people were saying things they
wouldn't necessarily say to your face if
they saw you in person
oh yeah they were acting like cyber
bullies we're gonna see what looks to be
a heated moment between you and kandi
coming whatever she said I'm embedded in
your hair but you could never be a busy
they do have way more extend to be in
big anything yeah I'm actually embedded
in her head and her friends head because
I'm all that they talk about it probably
made her feel really good because she
uses don't get to faith but she's so
boring what I'm taking away here is
we're not moving forward or in a
positive direction with kandi after this
no I think that you know kandi wanted
some smoke with me she created it
herself and so this is like something
that I guess she wanted so you got it
girl miss boring news fest I loved that
you owned that you pre wrote some reads
and had them handy at your computer yeah
well for me it's just like Andy he has
all of his questions written down and I
wanted to not forget to ask questions so
it wasn't about reads it was about
didn't want to forget to ask certain
questions because a lot of times when
I'm with these girls and I leave and I'd
be like dang I forgot to say that oh I
wish I hadn't said this I was trying to
ask that question so I wanted to make
sure I was prepared you know here the
questions that I needed to ask and so
nobody can ever talk about my reads I've
always sat on the couch and read
everybody from the top of my feet so
they can say whatever they want to say
they've been read for years for many
years and I have iconic one-liners that
are out there naive but not even trying
to make it anything it just became
something big I mean the list goes on
and on honey girl by the thirst is real
baby reached it's blue close your legs
to married me and trash box I mean I can
go all the doors close on and on and on
and on I said all those things you have
a favorite all-time and read that you've
delivered I really like blue I really
will give you a blue anytime I feel like
it blue they come again blue don't do me
honey trash pop my wig so those
questions you had written down it was
mostly questions not reads mostly
questions and read to let me
I just want to don't forget your face oh
yes get the receipts
yes actually I have some of them yes I
remember I had this right this is one I
call candy number two your number two
want to make sure that we remember to
tell you that your number too honey
don't want to get confused I think I
might have said this at some point I
think I did I don't think it's played
yet can you see that I can't see it just
it's like a white card to me because
it's I may have missed episodes but I
did not miss one check and they tease me
every episode until I showed up and
that's what I have on this car so put
anybody they have to say any thing about
me not getting the episode Nene don't
forget to let them know honey you ready
you never missed a check and you were
teased until you showed up and if I
wasn't needed they wouldn't have had to
team me honey they couldn't have teased
even everybody tuned in I mean who would
have tuned in for that so yeah girl I
got I love it you know our last
interview caused a little stir that I
wasn't expecting we have a great cast
right now except for one person I think
I think only one person on this cast
that seemed to have carried any weight
this season I don't think I might even
brings that much who she's bothered oh
honey you know every time we get
together honey you know we had way too
much tea going on they're gonna be mad
about this interview we're doing right
now for me everywhere they're gonna be
mellow let's get them clicking honey
let's get it oh I know after the reunion
did your opinion of where IVA stands in
the group changed did she bring it at
the Reunion and I won't be apologizing
period that is so becoming of a
grandmother
you said she'll Frank will get my baby
ex or whatever I wanted to be the under
that you just want to say that plumber
try to turn into a peach you were trying
to get on when I met you sweetheart
nobody cares about you being on carpet
17 years ago okay
I felt like Eva was you know Gretchen
just survived every time somebody's
handsome oh it was like they told her in
her meeting like I can see them now
sitting in a meeting with her and
telling her you've got to step it up Eva
you need to step it up I mean you're on
thin ice over here and I think you win a
name like okay I'm gonna step it up
every time somebody say something jump
in so she jumps in every single time
well we slapped her down so many times
she should be tired she should be fired
well I think Portia had the line of
episode one with you and Portia were
like the dream team at this reunion you
seemed to be on the same page a hundred
percent did you guys have beforehand to
kind of strategize or was that just
that's where we're at you know what we
had not talked and then in a matter of
fact when I first when I closed the
computer and they ended up going to a
much break i calls Portia that's the
first time we talked about it I called
her and I said Portia I gotta tell you
girl you are in there you are killing it
when we go back you
sit back and be quiet and let me take it
from there we decided week on the tag
team their ass and let's go and we would
knock in there as well Porsha came in
guns blazing Hennessy at the ready yes
yeah they don't need the band Hennessy I
don't know about that I want to see more
you did make history with the first
virtual walk off and I loved you came
back and said honey I'm menopausal child
anything can happen where you menopausal
I was exhausted I was tired I thought I
was on a court case and I didn't think
it was fair so whenever I got ready to
walk up I was just like I'm out I gotta
go pee and ain't no need me stand up
you're asking nobody nothing I don't
think it's fair to do that to me it just
really lets me know like it's insane how
much they swear they don't need me but
need me there are reports out there that
you walked away a couple times I did you
okay yeah
there's also report out there that you
walked away one time and just decided
not to met correct okay can you tell me
what drove me to the point where you
were like I can't sit through this
anymore same thing they do the whole
reunion is just meaning it's Nene honey
me me me me me me Nene to the point of I
said to Andy is there anybody else here
do you have any questions for anyone
else here besides just Nene let some of
these other girls work for their checks
Andy to Entertainment Bravo you paying
them aren't you
if you gotta just question me for three
hours they give me their check thank you
I mean come on might be serious this is
like if insane like you have all these
girls you decided that you wanted them
in all of your episodes and please make
all of your girls
we saw you also get muted by Andy
okay you want to mute me but I'm the
very person that you need to ask the
questions did anything surprise you
about the reunion again one of the
things that surprised me as I said
before is I'm not in every episode but
yet your reunion is all around me is it
it was very surprising that they were
bringing Jovana to the reunion and they
didn't decide to bring the cookie lady
they didn't have mark daily to bring
they didn't have Porsha's fiance Dennis
to brain all they had was my check need
to be doubled
thank you very much I checked need to be
double because the rest of your girls
live a false life you paying all these
girls to sit up and talk to me all day
can I get my raise please thank you very
much I mean when I saw that Jovana was
gonna be there I was surprised because I
thought the snake gate thing was kind of
resolved you know she's thirsty honey
she ain't never been on TV she wanted to
be on here by any means necessary
so I had to do was pick up the phone and
say a camera will be shining so she
shows up and they got her when she can
turn against me like if they thought it
was a good idea I feel sorry for her
because she will never be a cast mate
over here and that's so sad because she
has been used and abused by girl she
should feel very news I can't imagine
Bravo hiring her to do anything
if so they have dropped down in level
you are not holding back and I'm here
for it you know what I don't even see
any reason why Hall back you know after
everything that's been done to me I just
don't see any reason why why should I I
mean everybody has something they need
to say about me me well don't forget now
Nene can say something about cheap
payment I was just hoping my debt gets
bigger at any moment now
any moment now just looking for my check
to grow any any mom
for myself a drink to drink every time
you say get much me can I get my check
in the business you got all your girls
talking about they don't talk about
nothing but me buddy and I all the
episode maybe it makes sense true
entertainment make it makes it so where
does the group go from here because it
seems like we're in a very fractured
place after this reunion oh I thought it
was somewhere somewhat of a little bit
of a revolt like I've seen all three
parts that's right first okay I haven't
I feel like there's nowhere for me to go
like at this point it looks stupid to
continue to argue I've extended olive
branches to her because as people love
to say somebody's got to be the bigger
person right so I've extended olive
branches I've apologized I've agreed to
move on there's no reason for me to keep
walking around argue with her for nosey
the only reason why she want to have an
argument with me is just to have her
name lighter that was my name is such a
good day you know she wants her name to
be printed right next to mine honey okay
and so I feel like what they need to do
is have a big shake-up like a couple of
these girls need to move to friends or
move on out or wherever they gonna go go
on whether I'm here or not it doesn't
make any difference - peach holders need
to exit Missy okay wow that's a big
statement yeah because you know it it
just need to be something else like for
me I'm over it like what the hell yeah
keep talking to me for your car I mean
like girl yeah I gotta come up with
something else and then the next person
beside them confident same when it be
like oh it's okay she caught it one man
but I know you always wait till after
reunion the season wraps up to think
about your future with the show have you
thought about that at all how are you
feeling I have thought about my check
true entertainment my check I thought
about my check yes since I am everything
that everybody has to talk about I mean
don't you think I deserve a bigger check
hello
don't you think I deserve more money I'm
all about my money
where is my money my money about that
you
got your rest of your boring girls
you're spending dollars on put them to
work so if they show you the money
you're happy to come back it really
depends on my mental stability yeah I
want to be able to be in a good place
and I want to be able to have a friend
on the show it's one of the things that
I think isn't fair true entertainment
Bravo that everybody else get to have a
friend on the show but yet I don't get
to have a friend on the show everybody
means somebody in this situation and I'd
like to have a friend on the show of my
own someone that supports me just like
the rest of these girls have their
buddies walking around and being with
them it's only fair true entertainment
and Bravo thank you do you not feel that
Marlo is that person for you on the show
no I go I do not I and Marlo are friends
and but she's also friends with a lot of
these other girls Lauren is not friends
with all of us I mean although she would
come around and say hi to us and but
she's she's clear that you you want
someone independent from the group
that's right absolutely yes yes and yes
all right anything else we need to know
other than true entertainment where is
her money
that's right she win the diamond where
is my money no no I think we've covered
everything I haven't seen part two or
part three of the reunion so I don't
know what's in it I did not watch part
one I won't watch two and I won't watch
three all right well thank you for
making the time today I'm glad we could
get into that you're probably gonna get
me in some trouble I stay in trouble
okay I'm always in trouble it's evil
somebody else doing this interview
they're not in trouble
only I'm in trouble if I do it if you so
bring it on I'm ready for the trouble
I'm never away from trouble trouble
finds me so come on trouble come on come
on
I mean could trouble find its way to
Anini Lee spin off would you want your
own show you know there are certain
things about a spinoff for me it would
have to be a certain show cuz I've been
spinoff so it just has to be the right
thing I'm a grown woman I'm not a kid
I want to you know I want it to be a
certain type of show maybe it's time to
revisit the roadtrip show with you and
Kim that was announced years ago that
never happened maybe I think him and I
both have grown up a lot we're grown
we're adults and I feel feels weird to
me you know 40 and 50 we ride on a bus
around the world you know being kids
like I don't know that just seems stupid
maybe there's a evolved version of that
maybe there's like a trips kind of thing
where you take like luxury vacations or
something mellow missus luxury I think
we both can have a bath yeah this is
luxury I think we can do that one yeah
all right well maybe you can convince
him to come be your friend on the show
maybe that's the answer maybe yeah I
think she's happy with the check she
gets for that show she has over there
all right thank you so much Nene have a
great day take care of beeping come on
get this honey
[Laughter]
[Music]